welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of Rick and
Morty season 4 episode 8 the vat of acid
episode 1 of the series best episodes at
least since the season premiere and like
that episodes for both long crystals it
is filled with endless hypothetical
morning deaths to break down the
animation details of which we thankfully
got to instead of staying in a bed of
acid for 20 minutes I think I would have
loved that just as much and thanks to
privacy comm for sponsoring this episode
if you sign up now at privacy comm slash
new rock stars you can get 5 bucks today
to use on any purchase online anyway
let's get started the episode opens with
Rick's deal and a chemical plant the
episode was originally based on the
trope of open vats of acid and movies
like Tim Burton Batman in the DC Comics
it was based on this plant here does
evoke the ace chemicals plant and Batman
and the gangster suits are like the ones
worn by Jack Napier's crew in that movie
a rat and foreground goes up to chew on
the bone of a past rat killed by acid
and then caught in the acid blast itself
and the cycle resets with the new rat
just like more days time loops this
episode and how each time he resets he's
actually replacing a dead version of
himself from the beginning Morty hates
Rick's idea of the fake vat of acid we
jump into the vat of acid and I'll
release the bones they'll float up what
is this face you're making is you an
inventor that what part of a fake acid
VAT with built-in air supply and
quick-release bones isn't inventive
enough for you and when did my job
become pitching you ideas like how on
the word pitching Morty winces one eye
shut as if Rick's spittle finally broke
him and it just relenting and after
Rick's seatbelt gap last week notice how
this time the buckle and strap of his
seatbelt
have just been completely removed from
the ship Rick shows off his third arm
for a surprise quick draws like the one
he sprouted in the recent never Ricky
Morty episode and they throw themselves
in the ass holy Sh yeah what a guy says
hey which is the stereotypical Italian
mafia slang Tony Soprano name this boats
two guys taking us to God's put in the
marina next door oh yeah anyway the
title sequence ends differently this
episode
so title comes up on screen and we hear
the bubbling as if to say we are going
to spend this whole episode dealing with
acid bats as a concept also worth noting
this is one of the rare episodes with no
forced cuttin in the title now we got to
hear out this gangster story here and
then little Tommy flim flam's
running down the Hyperloop his ass is on
fire from xenon fluid but his AI
hologram is his own pee ha ha ha
whatever is going on here he brings up
AI Holograms like the one Rick had after
his death in the season premiere and I
like how they had to bleep out hole
instead of pee those damn censors always
okay with a concept of things but never
with the whole part Rick whittles
smaller add bones and when they throw
the rat in Morty gives it its air supply
and it just kind of smiles contently as
it breathes morty tries shooting them
but the blaster hasn't recharged so we
just lights the guys sleeve on fire Rick
takes it gonna charges it frying all
three of them the bosses arm though
remains intact with Morty's puny little
flames still burning as it floats in the
fake acid Rick mentions past all Rick
ideas as being cool dangerous it's worse
than when I was a pickle oh that's right
you weren't there for that turns out
kind of cool maybe there's a connection
there obviously referring to the pickle
Rick episode in which Rick's murderous
fun came to an end when he had to rejoin
Morty and the others had to sit through
therapy by comparison Rick criticizes
all Morty ideas as lame and disastrous
this is the cool thing you did without
me again
the awesome thing I guess you wanted a
dragon mm Wow LUN forget about timely -
you really got in on that Game of
Thrones fever right yeah Rick hated the
claw and horror special victims Morty
episode earlier this season and
correctly notes that the episode was
produced assuming demons would still be
popular at the time it aired they were
unable to predict its popularity
crumbling along with the amount of its
writers gave about its final season
Mordy brings back up is Big Ideas a
device that lets save your place like in
a video game but in real life so that
you can try stuff and then go back to
your save point yes Morty I saw it on
Futurama he's referring to the series
finale of Futurama which has a similar
time button in reset structure check out
Rick's spleen for more details on that
meanwhile the gadget Rick tinkers with
appears to be the phantasm sphere with a
sharp hook sticking out later
on the episode his new odds and ends
include the tech no global research
industries mutagen tube Ninja Turtles 2
the secret of the use Rick's responses
to Morty are way more bitter than normal
do you have any idea how much work would
have to go into a machine huh
you can't do it I can do anything
Morty and earlier he said you trying as
hard as you can to hurt me right now
proves my point let you know when you
have a point in the world will know when
I try to hurt rick is not screwing
around this episode and his revenge on
Morty definitely has a Scott tenorman
level of commitment to it so Rick
invents Morty's device and he first
gives it to Morty after creating a loop
in which he shoots him and while it's
not clear if he kills Morty here it is
still dark when you remember that Rick
later reveals that a version of the
person in a parallel timeline has two
horribly died in order for him to take
his place so Rick just shot his grandson
and definitely killed another version of
himself all just to begin to make his
petit point mr. goldenfold returns after
the season premiere he's voiced by our
bud Brandon Johnson and he explains his
fling with a rent there at juggler I am
now an expert blacksmith with several
STDs and a broken heart I beseech your
nasty little asses to speak on the
matter no further
Morty shows off these STDs by panting
him what's wrong with your dick Morty
uses a reset to neg Jessica and then he
launches into a montage set to eric
clapton's it's in the way that you use
it you resets to tempt fate with a
manhole and in the background there's a
movie theater with more key titles asked
to backdoor something and ball fondlers'
a trailer to which we previously saw an
interventional cable he resets for these
stupid purpose of ordering two orders of
what looks like mashed potatoes and
bread after his serving size is too
small
remember another Marty died just for
that he resets to go into a women's
locker room love that crazy poster never
skip lifts day he resets while playing a
video game rather than just setting a
save point in that game he resets to
sample every ice cream flavor and
there's a bunch of stupid names here
like candy canes Bolden Barry
Robbie Ruud remnar mint Rees in pieces
and butter Scott P suicide-by-cop and
one of those cops is a Shoney's
which calls back the season 3 premiere a
reality that like this one is all part
of Rick's trick
Morty runs over jaywalkers not one of
them is on his phone but that's you know
still not okay there's also a banner on
the building with a wristwatch
and the word reset kind of like what's
happened what's going what's what's
happened in here he steals a old man's
wheelchair now the building's behind him
are a wine bar called poor decisions and
there's an orange and green checker
window the same as that of Moe's Tavern
from The Simpsons Morty engages of what
looks like this gross alien orgy the
purple horse cow things i twitches and
ecstasy and then over to the right one
of those heads wears a [ __ ] mask more
teachings out from a porn store
the sign says used only and then the
music shifts as he hits it off with this
woman
[Music]
the sequence it's all the sweet and
tragic notes of the dialogue free
montage that opened Pixar's up her
bedside photo of Morty features whip
striking the sexy pose and they end up
making up and flying to Alaska to see
the Northern Lights but it crashes
there's this woman behind them praying
but then gets sucked out and now this
flight number is 571 making this a nod
to the tragic Uruguayan Air Force flight
571 which crashed in the Andes in 1972
with the passengers having to resort to
cannibalism which inspired the book and
film alive which it is it's what's
happening here the four survivors are
dressed in the coats and hats similar to
those of the South Park kids with the
red orange hoodie Morty is dressed up
like Kenny reflecting how alternate
versions of Morty have died over and
over look before we continue more people
than ever are working from home they're
shopping from home they're schooling
from home they're getting schwifty from
home hopefully not on the floor and with
that extra time on the internet there's
more opportunity than ever for hackers
to steal your information or your money
well thanks to privacy icon for
sponsoring this episode
privacy lets you make online purchases
using virtual burner cards for online
purchases this protects your identity
and bank information on the Internet and
it lets you control the limit on each
virtual card that really comes in handy
with the streaming services or video
conferencing apps that we're all using
right now so for example I've set up an
account with privacy and I Lake my bank
account I created a card specifically
for my monthly Netflix subscription
payment privacy will ding you with
lightning-fast precision if someone
tries to charge the card twice or if the
card exceeds the amount you set for it
no vendor can overcharge beyond the
limit that you have set it's simple it's
fast it's just one click they also offer
different plans there's a free one that
lets you create up to 12 cards a month
there's a pro plan where you can get 36
cards a month and 1% cash back on
purchases and then a team's plan for
small businesses there's also a privacy
Chrome extension where you can fill out
all of your card info to save time
one-click and all your details are
instantly entered just head to privacy
comm slash New Rock starts and sign up
for an account and as a special treat
for my viewers new customers will
automatically get five dollars to spend
on your first purchase for a limited
time only that's free money just go to
privacy icon slash new rock stars and
sign up now
more tea hikes to the plane tail and
instead of resetting he doesn't want
things to end with his love so he's
smushes his frostbitten fingers
dial nine-one-one Oh an the finger skin
sticks to the screen good John the
flowers Morty's hospital room have a
balloon reading
hope you wake up and Jerry stupidly
resets everything you knew he was gonna
screw this up somehow and the music
resets back to the rock theme and in
trying to reconnect with his soulmate
she pepper sprays him and he sits on the
device dooming him similar to how price
its on the time button in that Futurama
episode more he throws himself again
again in the gorilla cage letting them
pummel him to death I love how one of
his shoes flies up alright be Harambee
brick reveals that the reset button had
a darker truth to it I don't respect
time travel if ant-man and the wasp can
do it I'm not interested yeah weirdly
this doesn't did break the show's
longtime rule against time travel with
the snake episode also Rick dissing
ant-man in the wasp who's post-credits
scene was technically the first
introduction of time travel in the MCU
and don't get sucked into a time vortex
we won't be able to save you this
episode's co-writer Jeff loveness is
writing ant-man 3 from arbol rick
explains that each time morty respond he
actually took the place of a morty in a
parallel timeline who was horribly
killed to make room for him so that
whispah vapor when he respond was
actually his own disintegrating body
that's right you little [ __ ]
it's the prestige you prestigious how
many did I kill me Morty every time you
recess the smells Jessica's hair every
time you relived a satisfying fart
that's how many more days you've
incinerated you greedy little junky the
prestige is the Christopher Nolan film
in which Hugh Jackman's transporting man
magic trick requires the horrific murder
of a doppelganger the dead Morty's
include one suspended in midair as his
body melts another at his desk
another was his eyeball hanging out
maybe after that gorilla killed him in
the restaurant the reset causes blood to
shoot out of his mouth at Rick's
workstation he's drinking a potion and
then dies in Rick's spaceship he melts
on a date with Jessica dead on the couch
doing something dead on the toilet
dead playing basketball in his driveway
probably trying to loop over and over
again to perfect his free-throw dad on
his bed looking at his phone doing
something dead eating ice cream from the
bridge dead and holding three scoop cone
he's melted there too but the most
interesting to me one of these reset
loops shows morty in the memory mind
blowers chamber from these season 3
episode meaning morty in one of these
loops wanted to read this
certain horrible memories and then
loopback so now this Morty has to live
with whatever that dark information was
Rick converges all of these suffering
timelines and Morty's own consciousness
why do you know about the vagary Rick
has a vast reminder that no matter what
dimension every Rick has a trick up his
sleeve to use fake acid to fake his own
suicide
Morty says I was just having fun it was
Jeffrey Dahmer II so you aren't up on
your serial killers Jeffrey Dahmer was
the Milwaukee cannibal Rick's making fun
of Morty turning to cannibalism after
the crash SWAT teams the protesters
appear their signs include that's our
word Moscow more deeper Moscow Mitch
McConnel
honk if you hate Morty return the whales
meaning that we stole whales cannibalism
is a choice and safe space more than
blackface yikes
Rick points out the different groups
that Maul ready pissed off across these
various resets some grassroots meet you
activists the ACLU Jesus Morty the AARP
I don't want to talk about n-double-a-cp
gamergate morty is that Supreme Court
Justice Sonia Sotomayor AARP crime may
have been pushing that old man out of a
wheelchair and I'm guessing the
n-double-a-cp offense had to do with
that blackface sign now to piss off the
gamergate movement
I feel like Morty would have had to side
against the gamers who were more likely
to use that hashtag which is weird or
maybe they're mad that he cheated to get
that high score and slept with a game
journalist to get some press his
girlfriend it did seem like she could
have been a video game reviewer and of
course right as Morty jumps in the ass
his girlfriend returns to declare her
love but then turns away in tears so
close a SWAT officer who brought his own
ladle wants to be sure but morty shoots
him and as he dies he reaches out for
help but the other guy thinks he's acid
proof I'm acid proof all of you all of
you I'm gonna be rich
here's my ass take a good look spank it
feels like that guy had other stuff
going on Rick reveals that this is all
in an alternate reality not their home
reality meaning that even Morty's brief
chemistry with Jessica doesn't mean
anything I am gonna miss this place
though Johnny Carson still alive and on
the air 9/11 never happened and rocky
road ice cream has peanut butter instead
of marshmallow yeah that is two weeks in
Rio now that we get a 911 reference hey
I'm not complaining hey the post-credits
scene shows us this still on the air
Tonight Show with Johnny Carson and Ed
McMahon which often did have these
random bumper cards with Anna
and even when that Officer starts to
burn in the acid they continue to just
lower him all the way down it ends with
Johnny telling ed please kill me because
had he lived to 2020 Carson would be 95
years old and definitely would not want
to still be hosting the show check out
yesterday's episode of ER explained for
the deep dive into this episode's
time-loop structure how it connects to
future rama's finale and what rick's vat
of acid really tells us about his
self-destructive tendencies or adult I
know a lot of you just want to pretend
like you found all these jokes yourself
and then [ __ ] comment on YouTube
appreciators hey we follow me on
instagram and twitter i da boss small
indie rock stars and subscribe for more
Rick and Morty coverage you son of a
[ __ ]
[Music]